[Musica]
Piccoli brividi su questo canale Ne
abbiamo già parlato due volte ed oggi
farò una cosa che aspetto da tutta la
vita di fare sul canale riassumere tutti
i piccoli brividi della prima serie però
quella che io ho letto e che so quasi a
memoria e sono 62 libri Tra l'altro in
questa serie di libri C'è sempre un
Twist finale quindi con questo video Voi
potrete fare parecchi Drinking game
potrete bere ogni volta che dico Twist
ogni volta che dico fratelli ogni volta
che dico Bulli poi fate voi Mettetevi
comodi Prendetevi una bibita uno snack
perché sarà un lungo viaggio Questi sono
i piccoli brividi In poche parole
la casa della morte una famiglia di
quattro si trasferisce in una casa nuova
ma scopre che era tutto un piano del
loro agente immobiliare per nutrire dei
morti viventi che vivono nella casa con
il sangue degli inquilini il tuo finale
è che nonostante la famiglia sia
riuscita a scappare dalla casa la gente
immobiliare Porta nuove persone
all'interno dell'abitazione Tra l'altro
il paese in cui si trasferiscono si
chiama cascata tenebrosa cosa cazzo ti
aspettavi piccola curiosità per Stein
l'autore Questo libro è molto molto
molto spaventoso forse troppo e infatti
essendo il primo libro non aveva ancora
trovato diciamo la chiave comica a metà
tra loro relè la commedia Il mistero
dello scienziato pazzo l’illustratore
delle copertine di Piccoli Brividi si
chiama team yakbus e ha disegnato tutte
le copertine dei libri tranne due La
prima è questa due fratelli Scoprono che
il padre si rinchiude in cantina per
fare degli esperimenti sulle piante
viene fuori che il padre ha anche
provato a clonarsi più volte ed infatti
si scopre che il padre con cui loro
hanno parlato fino adesso non è il vero
padre ma un clone quindi distruggono
tutto quanto e riescono a liberare il
vero padre il twist è che in realtà loro
hanno salvato solo un altro clone è il
vero padre si è trasformato in un fiore
un barattolo mostruoso un ragazzino
scopre un barattolo di Slime verde che
piano piano esce dal barattolo e diventa
sempre più grande distruggendo tutto lui
pensa che sia colpa della zia che sembra
una strega ma in realtà no era colpa del
gatto uccidono il gatto e salvano la
situazione ma il twist è che dei
pezzettini di Slime sono ancora in
circolazione foto dal futuro un gruppo
di amici trova una macchina fotografica
che porta sfiga perché ogni volta che
fai una fotografia lei ti fa vedere una
cosa negativa che ti sta per accadere
Scoprono che la Creazione di uno
scienziato che tenta di fermarli Ma loro
scappano via e gli fanno una foto il
twist finale è che due deficienti
trovano la macchina fotografica e si
fanno un selfie mano di mummia nel
cinepanettone Natale al Cairo due cugini
più lo zio archeologo vanno a visitare i
corridoi di una piramide a Med un uomo
che supervisione i lavori alla Piramide
viene posseduto da uno spirito egiziano
e vuole Elencare tutti il twist è che il
portafortuna di uno dei tuoi cugini per
puro culo è un portafortuna che fa
rianimare le mummie che uccidono Ahmed e
li salvano guarda te la fortuna a volte
uno due tre invisibile due fratelli
scoprono uno specchio che li rende
invisibili ma invece di diventare che ne
so supereroi o fare qualcosa di buono
per l'umanità con questo potere i due
sono [__] e Scoprono che lo specchio
in realtà al potere di sostituire la
loro persona con quella riflessa per non
farsi scambiare da due persone del mondo
dello specchio lo mandano in frontoni
per far finire tutto il twist è che uno
dei due fratelli in questa realtà non è
più Mancino e forse è meglio così perché
mano mancina la morte si avvicina il
pupazzo parlante uno dei libri più
famosi della Saga Due Sorelle gemelle
hanno due pupazzi da ventriloquo slappy
e signor pezzo di legno a causa di un
fogliettino con una formula magica
trovata nel suo taschino il signor
gambadilegno si anima e inizia a fare
bordello loro per tutto il libro
riescono a non morire e a disintegrarlo
facendolo investire da una macchina
Santo cielo il twist è che leggendo quel
foglietto con la formula magica non solo
il signor gambadilegno si è animato ma
ora anche slappy l'altro lo sapevi che
slappy il pupazzo parlante è ispirato a
Pinocchio la madre di Stein gli leggeva
quando lui era piccolo Pinocchio prima
di andare a letto e lui si cagava
addosso nella scena in cui gli prendono
fuoco i piedi Io non capisco Però ecco
perché è diventato un autore horror
Adesso guarderò Pinocchio
al mostro al mostro
io lo leggo così perché per una storia
stupida ci vuole un titolo stupido una
ragazza scopre che il suo bibliotecario
è un mostro lo vede mangiare insetti
tutto uno schifo te lo ricordi perché ci
ho fatto il video io di questo della
puntata della serie
si fa aiutare da alcune persone per
farsi credere dai genitori perché
ovviamente non le credono e i genitori
invece di ucciderlo questo mostro o di
chiamare la polizia lo invitano a cena
perché il twist è che anche i genitori
sono dei mostri e se la mangiano Viva il
campeggio degli orrori Mettiti un attimo
qua l'una guarda lì un ragazzo viene
mandato in un campeggio chiamato luna
nera Ma le cose sono più strane del
previsto gente che sparisce strane
creature nel buio e non riescono a
contattare i propri genitori il twist è
uno dei miei preferiti si scopre che
tutti quelli nel campeggio erano
d'accordo perché in realtà non è un
campeggio è un campo di addestramento
militare segreto per fare in modo che il
protagonista venga addestrato per una
missione segreta da fare con i suoi
genitori su un pianeta chiamato terra
perché non ero ambientato sulla terra
sono
Il fantasma della porta accanto una
ragazza ha il sospetto che il suo vicino
di casa sia un fantasma il twist in
realtà è che è lei il fantasma mandata
sulla terra per salvare proprio il
vicino di casa da un incendio perfetto
lineare La maschera maledetta una
ragazza viene bullizzata a scuola quindi
si compra una maschera di Halloween
spaventosa per spaventare i bulli solo
che indossandola capisce di essere molto
più cattiva e a non riuscire più a
toglierla l'unico modo per rimuoverla è
trovare un simbolo d'amore verso di lei
e le viene in mente un regalo da parte
di sua madre riesce a trovarle riesce
finalmente a togliersi la maschera il
twist è che tornando a casa scopre che
adesso è il fratello ad aver indossato
una maschera maledetta Stain si è
ispirato a questa storia quando il suo
figlioletto Max per Halloween si è messo
una maschera del mostro di Frankenstein
e non riusciva più a toglierla
Santo cielo la sfera di cristallo Questa
è la seconda ed ultima copertina non
fatta da Tim una ragazza incontra un
genio che le chiede tre desideri da
esaudire Il primo è quello di diventare
la più brava nella sua squadra di basket
però lei diventa la più brava ma le
altre fanno comunque cagare Quindi
perdono sempre il secondo è quello di
far sparire la bulla che le dà fastidio
a scuola ma siccome lei dice i desideri
in modo un po' troppo generico il genio
per sbaglio fa sparire tutti quanti Il
terzo desiderio è quello di far tornare
tutto come era prima però con una
variante che la bulla sia sua amica il
genio esaudisce il desiderio Il problema
è che la bolla diventa troppo amica
diventa una di quelle persone
appiccicate che non ti mollano più
quindi la protagonista decide di fare
una cosa di tornare un pochino indietro
e di avere ancora un desiderio da
esaudire Ma se ne lava le mani dici
Guarda io non lo voglio più esaudire
fallo esaudire alla bolla non me ne
frega più niente il twist è che il
desiderio della Bulla è quello di
trasformare la protagonista in un
uccello così perché la odiava il
pianoforte è impazzito un ragazzo ha un
pianoforte in soffitta suonato da un
fantasma Dopo varie vicissitudini decide
di prendere lezioni di pianoforte in una
scuola da un inquietantissimo insegnante
quello che tu Pensavi fosse il nemico
cioè il fantasma che suona al pianoforte
in realtà è il più buono di tutti perché
lui scopre che in questa scuola sono
tutti i robot e il fantasma aveva
cercato di avvertirlo il twist di tutta
questa storia è che il robot che ha
creato la scuola Senti qua adora la
musica ma non riesce a suonarla perché
non ha le mani e sono troppo difficili
da costruire Quindi se inventato tutto
sto ambaradan di scuola per
rapire persone e rubargli le mani per
poter suonare il pianoforte Questa è una
delle storie più imbecille di Piccoli
Brividi posso dirlo il lupo della Palude
un ragazzino si trasferisce la propria
famiglia vicino ad una palude incontra
un vicino di casa che si scopre essere
un licantropo una notte viene attaccato
e morsicato da questo licantropo Ma
grazie a Dio il suo cane arriva in tempo
per salvarlo Come vuoi che finisca il
twist è che il morso ha trasformato
anche lui in un licantropo che piano
piano si trasforma in questo lupo e da
lupo lui insieme al cane scappano
insieme questa storia d'amore improvvisa
di lui che corre tutto peloso col cane a
fianco che salutano i genitori La notte
dei mostri di fango un gruppo di amici e
infastidito da una loro compagna che
sembra non aver paura di nulla per tutto
il libro loro cercano di farla
spaventare per tutto il libro tanto che
la attirano in un bosco e si travestono
da mostri di fango per farle prendere
uno spavento il twist è che nella
foresta esistono davvero dei mostri di
fango che fanno cagare tutti addosso
questo è abbastanza semplice
sarebbe stata particolare questo libro
inizia con una famiglia che parcheggia
la propria auto nel parcheggio di un
parco divertimenti a tema scende e
l'auto esplode come in Gomorra Scoprono
che questo parco è veramente un parco
degli orrori perché gestito da veri
mostri dopo mille peripezie riescono a
fuggire rubando un pullman del parco il
twist è che scoprono Mentre stanno
scappando che uno dei mostri si è
aggrappato al loro pullman e loro si
cagano addosso perché ha detto Oh mio
Dio ci mangerà invece no il mostro si
era aggrappato soltanto per regalargli
due biglietti gratis per l'anno dopo
questo io dico Gardaland Pensaci che non
è male nascondere tipo prezzemolo me
nelle nei sedili dietro di un'auto per
far cagare tutti in mano volete dei
biglietti così non lo so Pensaci questo
libro ha una copertina che da piccolo
non riuscivo proprio a guardare per ovvi
motivi un insopportabile ronzio un
ragazzo costantemente bullizzato
solo perché esiste un'agenzia che gli
permette di scambiare la propria
coscienza con un'altra persona durante
l'operazione dentro il macchinario cosa
vuoi che succeda entra un'ape e lui
invece di scambiarsi con l'altra persona
scambia la propria coscienza con l'Ape
un po' come il film La mosca Ironia
della sorte scopre che invece il ragazzo
che si doveva scambiare in lui ce l'ha
fatta è diventato lui ed è diventato
super Popolare giusto per ricordare il
protagonista che era proprio un problema
di personalità cioè la lui era proprio
una merda di persona il protagonista ape
incazzato nero con questa cosa qua dice
sai cosa piuttosto che fargli vivere la
mia vita da Popolare lo pongo e moriamo
tutti quanti ma in realtà quando lo
punge si risveglia e sembra essere
tornato tutto alla normalità ma il twist
è che anche se lui è tornato umano sente
questa estrema necessità di annusare i
fiori un barattolo mostruoso numero 2 il
primo sequel della Saga a sto giro lo
Slime del barattolo viene fatto mangiare
ad un criceto che diventa gigantesco
tipo Kaiju e inizia a distruggere tutto
il protagonista per salvare la
situazione decide anche lui di mangiare
lo Slime e di diventare gigantesco per
affrontare il criceto ma il barattolo si
scopre essere scaduto tipo uno yogurt e
quindi tutti e due ritornano alla
normalità il twist è che c'è un altro
barattolo in circolazione e per sbaglio
il criceto Ne mangia un pochino mortacci
sua sto crescendo de merda terrore dagli
abissi due fratelli fanno visita ad uno
zio su una piccola isola scoprono non
solo che esistono mostri marini ma anche
delle sirene che alcuni Cacciatori
vogliono rapire ma per mille motivi
diversi sono i protagonisti ad essere
rapiti e le sirene a salvarli il twist
non è neanche un Twist il fratellino si
butta in acqua a fine libro è un mostro
acquatico sta per mangiarselo Ecco
esattamente come i livelli subacquei dei
videogiochi Questo libro è una delusione
spaventapasseri viventi Chissà di cosa
parlerà due fratelli vanno a visitare i
nonni in campagna che hanno parecchi
spaventa pensieri nel loro campo di
grano che ogni tanto si animano cercando
di capire cosa succede Scoprono che un
contadino li ha animati con una formula
magica i nonni che sapevano tutto gli
avevano chiesto a questo contadino per
favore Spegniti Il contadino per
ricattarli e ha detto se volete io ve li
spengo però voi in cambio mi dovete
cucinare tutto quello che voglio che per
dei nonni Secondo me è una richiesta
abbastanza valida alla fine riescono a
distruggerli tutti il twist però è che
questo cazzo di contadino legge di nuovo
la formula magica ma questa volta vicino
ad un orso impagliato che si anima e
attacca i protagonisti Ma perché
vendetta strisciante il protagonista è
un appassionato di vermi dopo aver perso
un concorso di scienze a scuola inizia a
prendersela con loro torturandoli e
uccidendoli come credo Tutti i bambini
abbiano fatto nella loro vita Sei un
mostro tu un gigantesco verme esce fuori
dal terreno e tenta di uccidere lui la
sorella lo salva il twist è che questo
libro è un prequel di Tremors Non è vero
il twist è che lui dopo essersi
appassionato ai vermi ad essere stato
attaccato da uno gigante dice vabbè
basta vermi Forse è meglio le farfalle
ed infatti viene attaccato da una
farfalla gigante
ok La spiaggia degli spettri due
fratelli visitano due loro cugini per le
vacanze durante le vacanze incontrano
tre vicini di casa molto ospitali ma
anche quello che sembrerebbe un fantasma
in una grotta in questo libro I twist
sono tre Il fantasma della Grotta in
realtà non è un fantasma ma un
ricercatore poverino che gli è andato
del fantasma i veri fantasmi sono quei
tre vicini di casa cordiali e il cane
che abbaia ai fantasmi abbaia anche ai
due cugini dell'inizio sto aspettando
che forse siano anche loro due fantasmi
il ritorno della Mummia e ritornano
finalmente la ragazzina e lo zio
archeologo a sto giro insieme a loro si
unisce una giornalista
e riescono a trovare il sarcofago di un
principe egiziano il principe ovviamente
torna in vita e si scopre che la
giornalista e sua figlia dopo tutto
quanto sconfiggono la mummia ma al Twist
è che la giornalista la figlia del
principe egiziano si trasforma in uno
scarabeo scappa e nessuno la trova più
il fantasma del palcoscenico due amici
diventano i protagonisti di una recita
scolastica chiamata Il fantasma del
palcoscenico c'è qualcuno che durante le
prove fa scherzi e malefatte a tutti gli
organizzatori e tutti pensano che sia un
fantasma che risiede nel palco di un
bambino morto 72 anni fa in realtà un
primo twist che forse anche più bello di
quello finale non è un fantasma di un
bambino morto 72 anni fa che fa gli
scherzi ma è un senzatetto che abita
sotto al palco e non voleva e voleva che
nessuno lo scoprisse il twist vero è che
durante la recita scolastica ufficiale
appare è vero il bambino fantasma morto
72 anni prima ma chi se ne frega c'è un
senzatetto che abita sotto il palco da
chissà quanto tempo e nessuno dice
niente chiamate qualcuno dategli un
panino qualcosa l'attacco del mutante e
anche di questo ci ho fatto un video
dell'episodio televisivo Skipper un
ragazzino che ama i fumetti del mutante
mascherato scopre in città un edificio
che è identico a quello dei fumetti del
mutante mascherato decide di entrarci
con una sua amica senza sapere che è
proprio la sua amica ad essere in
mutande mascherato e siccome il mutante
mascherato è un villain nei nei fumetti
Skipper in difficoltà quindi decide di
ucciderlo è l'unico modo per uccidere il
mutante mascherato che si può
trasformare e dirgli trasformati in
acido e lui dice va bene guarda cosa so
fare si trasforma in acido e muore
perché il deficiente di merda si
dimentica che se si trasforma in un
liquido non si può più ritrasformare in
un solido e quindi muore così come un
pirla il twist che Skipper dopo essersi
fatto un taglio sulla mano esce il
sangue di tutti i colori perché anche
lui è diventato un supereroe un tragico
esperimento allora un ragazzino ha dei
problemi se non mi ricordo male
collegandole sudoripare quindi deve
farsi fare delle iniezioni regolari da
un dottore solo che sia lui sia i suoi
amici
iniziano a vedere che gli crescono dei
peli da tutte le parti iniziano proprio
a crescere i peli a tutti i ragazzini e
vedono anche che i loro genitori si
comportano in modo molto strano che sono
un po' Vaghi e hanno dei comportamenti
particolari il twist di questa trama è
che si scopre che il dottore ha fatto
degli esperimenti in tutta la città dove
ha trasformato i cani in bambini e
quelle iniezioni che fai i bambini
servono per mantenere la trasformazione
perché se tu non ti fai l'iniezione dopo
un po' giorni ad essere carne tutti i
bambini che ci sono in città In realtà
sono cani e i dottori decide basta Non
ho più voglia di fare questo esperimento
e tutti i bambini tornano cani e i
genitori sono rimasti senza bambini
è pieno di cavi in giro il twist finale
di questo delirio e che il protagonista
ormai ritornato cane vede i suoi ex
genitori portare a casa una sorellina
che in teoria sarebbe un gatto
leggetelo ma poi non venitemi a scrivere
perché fa paura prigionieri della torre
due fratellini a Londra decidono di
andare a visitare una fantomatica Torre
chiamata la torre del terrore dove una
guida Spiega loro che in questa torre
durante il medioevo venivano rinchiusi
due principi subito dopo vengono
inseguiti da un uomo in nero che per
tutto il tempo cerca di catturarli alla
fine riesce a catturarli e li spedisce
indietro nel tempo nel Medioevo per
scoprire poi il twistone sono loro due i
due fratellini in realtà i due principi
che venivano rinchiusi nella torre in
quel periodo nel Medioevo sarebbero
dovuti essere giustiziati ma un mago li
salva spedendoli avanti nel futuro cioè
nel presente della storia
cancellandogli la memoria riescono a
salvarsi a tornare nel presente insieme
anche al mago che diventa una guida
turistica la Pendola del destino questa
storia Santo cielo Michael è un
ragazzino di 12 anni che subisce tutti i
dispetti della sorellina stronza Quindi
quando il padre porta a casa un orologio
a pendolo con il cucù lui decide di far
uscire il cucù girargli la testa al
contrario questo povero uccellino e dare
la colpa alla sorella ma scopri che
facendo questa cosa qua il tempo inizia
ad andare al contrario ogni giorno torna
sempre più indietro nel tempo Anno dopo
anno sempre di più senza sosta
continuano a passare i mesi le settimane
e gli anni Anno dopo anno è un film di
Lynch ma per bambini e quando ritornato
ad un anno di età piccolissimo riesce a
trovare questo orologio a cucù e a
sistemare la testa e a tornare nel
presente ma c'è un piccolo problema che
è il twist della storia la sorella nel
presente non c'è più perché il padre
questo orologio a cuculo ha portato a
casa avendolo preso con forte sconto
perché ha un difetto il difetto è che
l'anno di nascita della sorella che è il
1988 non c'è e come se tornando indietro
nel tempo avesse cancellato skippato
l'anno di nascita della sorella e
andando avanti avesse resettato la
sorella e quindi è sparita e siccome la
sorella gli faceva tanti dispetti lui
potrebbe sistemare la situazione ma
aspetta un attimo a farlo
e terrificante questa storia un
barattolo mostruoso numero 3 Wow la
trilogia
terzo episodio dello Slime che
ingigantisce cose a sto giro per colpa
di uno scherzo andato a [__] lo Slime
finisce in bocca al protagonista che
ovviamente diventa gigantesco per
fermarlo arrivano pure polizia e vigili
del fuoco tipo King Kong ma con l'aiuto
di due suoi amici riescono a creare un
altro liquido blu che bevendolo lo fa
rimpicciolire e tornare normale il twist
Molto ironico e che l'intruglio lo fa
rimpicciolire Ma non è che lo fa fermare
a un certo punto infatti passa un giorno
da quando è tornato normale e si
risveglia microscopico un mostro in
cucina due fratelli trovano sotto il
lavello nella loro casa in vacanza Un
mostro a forma di spugna per lavare i
piatti questa creatura si nutre di odio
Quindi tu più provi a massacrarle a
ucciderla più lei ti porta sfiga come
una versione
SpongeBob SquarePants delle catene di
Sant'Antonio Quindi loro fanno l'opposto
le danno tantissime coccole e tantissimo
amore e lei si indebolisce e muore il
twiste che sotto il lavabo trovano una
seconda creatura una patata con i denti
Io amo Questi libri Il pupazzo parlante
numero due solita storia viene portato
slappy in una famiglia dove ci sono tre
fratelli e un altro pupazzo da
ventriloquo di nome vennis slappy si
anima e fa casino i ragazzini lo dicono
ai genitori che ovviamente non gli
credono il twist e che slappy viene
distrutto da uno dei tre fratelli ma in
realtà non era uno dei tre fratelli era
l'altro pupazzo Dennis travestito quindi
il twist è che slappy viene ucciso ma
Dennis e anche lui animato La cosa
curiosa è che tutti si ricordano di
slappy del pupazzo parlante ma nel primo
libro slappy appare soltanto alla fine
perché il protagonista è il signor
gambadilegno un po' come il silenzio
degli inno perché tutti se lo ricordano
per Hannibal Lecter ma Hannibal Lecter
C'è per due minuti nel silenzio degli
innocenti Infatti quando fecero la
puntata della serie TV del pupazzo
parlante non fecero quello del primo
libro ma fecero quello del secondo
perché slappy era il protagonista quindi
probabilmente siccome era diventato
iconico volevano far vedere direttamente
lui quindi ha detto Vai Facciamo che il
primo episodio è quello del secondo
libro I cani fantasma con una copertina
che ricorda quella di cujo il libro di
Stephen King Cooper Inizia ad essere
perseguitato da due cani che solo lui
vede insieme alla sua vicina di casa
Fergie Scoprono che questi due cani in
realtà non sono cani ma sono due
ragazzini trasformati in cani che
cercano altri due corpi per tornare
umani ed infatti questi due cani
fantasma fanno un piano per incastrare i
due protagonisti e scambiarsi i corpi e
ce la fanno i due protagonisti diventano
i cani e i due cani diventano due
protagonisti quindi Cooper e Ferdi due
protagonisti che adesso sono diventati
cani pianificano un'operazione
per riprendersi i colpi il twist è che
il piano va a buon fine i due
protagonisti riescono a fare lo scambio
di corpi Ma mentre lo fanno in quel
momento nella foresta passano due
scoiattoli e loro diventano due
scoiattoli quindi Beh dai poteva andare
peggio potevano essere un'ape un mostro
in vacanza l'incipit di questo libro mi
ha fatto sempre molto molto ridere Due
Fratelli viaggiano con i genitori in
macchina ma siccome si stanno un po'
rompendo le balle chiedono i genitori
possiamo almeno farci il viaggio nella
roulotte che abbiamo attaccato dietro i
genitori dicono sì loro salgono sulla
roulotte ma appena salgono sulla
roulotte la roulotte si stacca dalla
macchina e loro tornano indietro
mi sono sempre immaginato i genitori che
si fanno tipo 46 km e poi dicono Come
vanno i ragazzi
Oh Madonna mia che ci sono onore questa
roba Ah che stanno tornando indietro
Esatto vengono ritrovati da un animatore
di un villaggio vacanze che ha che
questo villaggio vacanze ha come
mascotte un obbrobrio chiamato re Vichy
Gommolo in questo centro per ragazzi si
fanno delle sfide tra ragazzi e chi
perde sparisce e non si ha idea di dove
finisca Ma poi li trovano si scopre che
il re viscigommolo la mascotte del parco
in realtà esiste davvero è una creatura
terribilmente puzzolente che deve essere
lavata costantemente
dai perdenti delle sfide Ecco dove
finivano finivano a pulire la cera
Azzurra fa un po' schifo però sai come
lo ammazzano i protagonisti riescono a
far smettere di lavare il mostro e la
puzza diventa così forte che lui muore
soffocato dalla sua dai suoi stessi
fetori il twist finale in realtà non è
neanche un vero e proprio Twist lui
torna a casa e quando torna a casa sente
lo stesso identico fetore a rivadere
dalla cucina e dice oh Madonna Il mostro
è tornato invece era la madre che
cucinava cavolfiori
la vendetta degli gnomi piccola
curiosità sulla copertina sta in voleva
che nella copertina ci fosse lo gnomo
con il dito nel naso ma la casa editrice
disse erstein No non vogliamo mettere
uno gnomo col dito nel naso e allora la
fece cambiare e adesso lo gnomo ha il
dito fuori dal naso che non c'è una
posizione Terribile però è questa il
padre di due fratelli è pazzo per il
giardinaggio E difatti un giorno torna a
casa con delle statue di gnomo che
ovviamente si animano i due fratelli
vengono anche rapiti da tutti gli gnomi
che si trovano in un negozio di quelli
tipo Viridea e vengono salvati soltanto
dal fischietto per cani di uno dei due
che quando lo utilizza trasforma tutte
tutti gli gnomi in statue di gesso e si
salvano veramente una monnezza di storia
gli orrori di shock Street è una mantide
perché la trama è due amici fanno il
giro di un parco a tema film horror
e Scoprono che tutti gli orrori che
li hanno inseguiti per il parco sono
veri scheletri licantropi Zombie mantidi
ma ad un certo punto la protagonista va
in cortocircuito perché si scopre che i
due protagonisti in realtà erano due
robot creati dal proprietario del parco
per testare le attrazioni
La maschera maledetta 2 Tra l'altro la
maschera maledetta il libro preferito
dastein Steve mentre in compagnia del
suo amico Chuck ruba una maschera da un
negozio una maschera di Halloween se la
mette e non riesce più a toglierla
Allora è costretto a contattare la
protagonista del primo libro lui e lei
tornando al negozio Scoprono che la
maschera si toglie automaticamente per
unirsi a tutto il resto del costume ed
il twist finale è che si scopre che
Chuck la prima volta che loro sono
andati al negozio anche lui ha rubato
una maschera e non riesce più a
togliersela Bravo [__] il fantasma
senza testa due sorelle sono attratte da
una villa in collina perché una guida
turistica dice loro che è abitata dal
fantasma di un capitano di Nave il twist
che il fantasma in realtà è la guida
turistica questi sono quei libri alla
Scooby Doo dove l'unico personaggio che
potrebbe essere in villain è
effettivamente il villain il mostro
delle quindi a pasa Dina un padre due
fratellini fanno un classico viaggio di
famiglia vanno fino in Alaska per
cercare un mostro delle nevi che trovano
chiuso in un cubo di ghiaccio dentro un
gruppo il ghiaccio si rompe e Scoprono
che il corpo del mostro è molto molto
caldo prima di tornare a casadina loro
si portano dietro sia al Mostro sia tre
palle di neve perché a casadina non
nevica mai quindi lavo loro la volevano
far vedere i propri amici solo che
queste palle di neve congelano ogni cosa
che toccano un fratellino la tira la
sorellina e la congela Quindi lui cosa
fa disperato libera il mostro che hanno
portato a casa per scongelare la sorella
solo che il mostro scappa e non riescono
più a trovarlo Il mostro non si sa più
che fine abbia fatto e loro per evitare
di fare altri casini sotterrano queste
palle di neve il twist è che altri due
ragazzini le le scavano prendono fuori
queste palle di neve se le tirano
addosso a vicenda rimane tutto
completamente in sospeso quindi a pasa
Dina attraverso di Piccoli Brividi c'è
un mostro che corre libero e due
deficienti congelati una testa di mummia
per mois Mark è un dodicenne che scopre
di avere un potere che la zia gli ha
regalato può comandare le piante grazie
alla testa di una mummia tutto a caso ma
la zia è sparita tanti anni prima in una
giungla Quindi lui e gli amici della zia
partono per andarla a salvare solo che
ovviamente tutti 'sti amici della zia
Sono dei pezzi di merda Quindi se lo
vogliono [__] e quindi e quindi
vogliono solo utilizzare il suo potere
per scoprirlo malvagi Quindi lui scappa
riesce a trovare la zia e tornano a casa
il twist di questa storia terribile e
che la testa di mummia che lui usa per i
suoi poteri in realtà è ancora viva
il pupazzo parlante 3 solita storia
ormai quei libri del pupazzo parlante
due fratellini hanno un padre che un ex
ventriloquo e ha 12 pupazzi da
ventriloquo in soffitta uno di questi
che si chiama Rocky si anima e inizia a
fare i dispetti ai due fratellini loro
lo dicono i genitori e i genitori non
gli credono un giorno il padre ne porta
un altro di pupazzo a casa chiamato
Smiley matuisone dei Toy Story Smiley
non è Smiley Smiley è slappy Eccolo qua
slappy si mena con Rocky che si mena con
i due fratelli quindi c'è questa zuffata
incredibile botte sangue ovunque tanto
che anche tutti gli altri 12 pupazzi si
sono rotti le balle e attaccano slappy
distruggendolo il twist finale è che in
realtà slappy è ancora vivo e lo
regalano al cugino sono cazzi suoi
adesso magico inganno Oh finalmente un
libro sui maghi Team vorrebbe andare a
vedere lo spettacolo del grande mago
Amazon Ma i genitori non vogliono quindi
lui è la sorella sgattaiolano fuori
dall'appartamento e lo fanno vedere
comunque viene scelto proprio Team per
fare da assistente da mago che però lo
mette in una scatola finisce in una
cantina e lui se la prende per questa
cosa qui quindi TIM per vendicarsi va
nel camerino del Mago gli ruba la
valigetta e la porta a casa in questa
valigetta c'è una carota credo per i
trucchi di magia col coniglio che la
sorella mangia e si trasforma in un
coniglio tornati dal mago per chiedere
spiegazioni scoprono il twist che il
mago che loro hanno visto in realtà è un
fantoccio comandato dal vero mago che
però è trasformato in coniglio che ha
trasformato la sorella in coniglio Per
usarla come coniglio negli spettacoli
teatrali che cazzo mostri dallo spazio
questa storia è intrigante un dodicenne
scopre un nuovo alieno questo uovo si
schiude e da dentro esce un nuovo
strapazzato alieno con gli occhi lo
porta ad un laboratorio e lo scienziato
gli dice che non c'è nulla di nuovo
perché ultimamente ne sono piovuti
tantissimi da Marte di questi alieni e
per non far uscire questa notizia lo
scienziato chiude il protagonista
insieme a tutti gli altri alieni dentro
una gabbia dentro la gabbia a quanto
pare Fa molto freddo quindi gli alieni
coprono il protagonista per farlo
sopravvivere al freddo e lo aiutano a
scappare il disturbantissimo twist e che
lui quando torna a casa
depone un nuovo in giardino il ragazzino
depone un uovo quindi vuol dire che
quando L'hanno coperto dal freddo quella
notte non l'hanno solo coperto lo hanno
fecondato
Stain il bosco dei mostri blu tre
fratelli di cui due gemelli si perdono
in mezzo ad un bosco e trovano queste
creature blu che vogliono fare un gioco
con loro uno viene marchiato e deve
passare il suo marchio ad altri
giocatori un po' Come ce l'hai e deve
anche raggiungere un albero della
salvezza in tempo altrimenti moriranno
tutti falliscono e stanno per essere
mangiati ma due di loro essendo gemelli
vengono considerati di livello più alto
e quindi lasciati andare a livello
superiore non so il twist è che però
dopo andando avanti incontro con altri
mostri blu di livello come il loro e
loro dicono Eh noi siamo gemelli quindi
possiamo passare e i mostri dicono no no
Voi siete allo stesso livello nostro
quindi dovete giocare di nuovo per la
vostra vita Stain cosa cazzo ti sei
fumato foto dal futuro numero 2 Un anno
dopo le vicende del primo libro Greg e
la sua amica Shari vogliono ritrovare la
macchina fotografica per farla al loro
professore che non ci crede per uno
sbaglio si fa non le foto a vicenda la
foto di Shari esce in negativo la foto
di Greg fa vedere lui o preso ed infatti
è quello che succede Greg inizia ad
ingrassare a dismisura e Shari avendo la
foto in negativo inizia a dimagrire
quindi capiscono che se invertono i
negativi delle foto quindi Greg mette la
foto in negativo e sciari la mette
normale e uno ingrassa l'altro
dimagrisce quindi ritornano normali il
twist è che il professore che non crede
a sta cosa della macchina fotografica fa
una foto all'intera classe Che paura
hectoplasmi perché c'è il punto
esclamativo due fratelli Vanno ad un
campo estivo chiamato spirito lunare
solo che c'è qualcosa di particolare in
questo campo tutti gli altri ragazzi che
partecipano hanno comportamenti strani e
sembrano non sentire dolore questo
perché in realtà tutti questi ragazzi
che i due fratelli trovano sono fantasmi
che hanno bisogno di possedere un corpo
umano per ritornare umani Il problema è
che questi fantasmi non riescono a
decidere quali fantasma debba andare con
quale fratello e quale fratello
possedere perché sono troppi quindi
iniziano ad azzuffarsi a massacrarsi da
tra di loro e a morire uno dopo l'altro
il twist è che anche se i due fratelli
sono riusciti a scappare uno di loro due
potrebbe essere in realtà posseduto
minaccia nel fango il twist di questo
libro due fratellastri che già questo è
un piccolo Twist Scoprono che i nonni
nascondono un mostro in una stanza
decidono così di cercare di ucciderlo e
tentano di fargli una torta avvelenata
tentano di spingerlo giù dalle scale ma
non funziona niente in questo libro ci
sono due Twist quello finale che vi
racconto subito cioè loro riescono a
uccidere il mostro e Scoprono che nel
resto del mondo ci sono altri mostri
liberi ma secondo me il miglior Twist è
quello che succede poco prima sapete
come uccidono il mostro questo mostro
sta per mangiare la sorella le lecca un
braccio si ferma e dice
Ma siete umani e lei dice sì E lui dice
Ah ma io sono allergico agli umani e
muore
La leggenda perduta due fratelli
accompagnati dal padre si avventurano
nella foresta per cercare un manoscritto
inseguono un cane che li porta alla
foresta fantastica dove tra mille
peripezie e mille creature mille
personaggi Scoprono che tutta questa
foresta in realtà erano tutta finte
erano tutti burattini erano tutti i
robot e che tutto era una prova per loro
da superare Tra l'altro Questa è l'unica
copertina che ti spoilera un pochino il
libro con la frase che c'è scritta sopra
è un robot una marionetta spoiler Alla
fine però trovano il baule con il
manoscritto che cercavano solo che la
leggenda dice che chi troverà il
manoscritto sarà perduto ed infatti Loro
si perdono le zucche della vendetta
Deriu è una ragazzina molto magra ed è
importante per la trama saperlo lei e i
suoi amici hanno sempre fatto dolcetto
scherzetto ad Halloween Solo che stanno
iniziando a diventare un pochino troppo
grandicelli quindi decidono di farlo per
l'ultima volta dopo essere stati un po'
spinti in un quartiere sconosciuto
scoprono il twist che due dei loro amici
sono degli alieni che mangiano persone
ma Deriu non viene mangiata perché gli
alieni mangiano soltanto persone grasse
alito di vampiro due amici trovano in
cantina una fiasca con scritto alito di
vampiro la aprono ed esce un vampiro che
Twist questo Conte chiamato ala della
notte non ha più i poteri e non trova
più i suoi denti quindi deve tornare
indietro nel tempo nel suo periodo per
ritrovare tutto quanto torna indietro ma
per sbaglio tornano anche indietro i due
protagonisti tra mille avventure
Riescono a tornare nel presente insieme
al Conte lo vanno a dire i genitori ma
si scopre che i genitori sanno benissimo
chi sia questo vampiro e il nonno è il
nonno e loro gli hanno tenuto la
dentiera in bagno Giusto in caso
i genitori e il nonno sono vampiri
quindi si trasformano tutti e tre i
pipistrelli e volano via fuori dalla
finestra
il twist forse è ancora più imbecille I
Due ragazzi nel bagno dove c'era la
dentiera del vampiro nonno trovano una
fiasca con scritto sudore di lupo
mannaro e la aprono Questi imbecilli di
merda bastardi cretini
metamorfosi totale ricchi È un ragazzino
che viene costantemente bullizzato a
scuola anche dalla sua direttrice del
giornale scolastico a cui lui partecipa
che lo chiama essere strisciante Dio mio
dei bulli poi lo rapiscono e lo portano
in una foresta dove si scopre che in
realtà non sono umani sono dei
rettiliani viscidi e siccome la
direttrice del giornale l'ha chiamato
essere viscido davanti a tutti loro
credono che Ricky sia il loro capo e gli
dicono anche che vogliono trasformare
tutta la scuola in rettiliani e ricchi
prima ci penso un e poi accetta di farlo
perché tanto la sua vita era una merda
Quindi tanto vale essere il capo dei
rettiliani Il mistero della caverna di
ghiaccio una ragazzina vuole andare
sulla cima di una montagna innevata ma
tutti quanti le dicono per l'amor di Dio
non andare anche un vecchio eremita che
vive lì le dice stai ferma non andare ma
lei ci va comunque e scopre che in cima
alla montagna c'è un pupazzo di neve che
si anima e le parla dicendole io sono
tuo padre e tua zia e tua madre mi hanno
trasformato in un pupazzo di neve Pensa
che giornata La madre la zia dicono non
è vero quello è un mostro che noi
abbiamo trasformato per tenerlo a bada
mentre il pupazzo dice Non è vero Io
sono tuo padre sono loro stronze che mi
hanno trasformato la povera ragazzina
dice Mannaggia questo è mio padre voglio
in tutti i modi ritrasformarlo in umano
lo ritrasforma in umano Ma il twist è
che in realtà non era il padre era
effettivamente un mostro che cercavano
di tenere a bada sta per andare ad
ammazzare tutti ma grazie a Dio si
salvano e il video proprio twiste e che
il padre della ragazzina in realtà è
l'Eremita sulla montagna il ragazzo
volante Masini questo libro ha il
protagonista che è un cazzo di genio del
male Jack è un ragazzino sfigatello che
è in perenne competizione con Wilson un
suo compagno di scuola che però vince
tutte le sfide Wilson perché è molto più
bravo è molto più intelligente tanto più
bravo che gli ruba anche la ragazzina
che ha Jack piace un giorno Jack trova
un libro che è una guida per imparare a
volare e questo libro effettivamente
funziona bevendo un intruglio lui impara
a volare Quindi lui va a scuola per far
vedere a tutti che sa volare Ah Guardami
Wilson E mo che fai Ma Wilson che lo
aveva di nascosto seguito scopre anche
lui il libro e anche lui vola e tra
l'altro anche lì Wilson vola molto
meglio di Jack e quindi anche quando
fanno una gara di volo Wilson vince nel
frattempo sia il padre di Jack sia il
padre di Wilson
esempio lucrare sul superpotere dei loro
figli e quindi li mettono in vendita e
diventano dei fenomeni da baraccone però
Jack non riesce più a volare il suo
potere è finito quindi Wilson vince tra
virgolette anche questa sfida e viene
preso dal governo per essere studiato e
sparisce il twist e che in realtà Jack
sa volare ma ha fatto finta di non saper
più volare per evitare di fare la fine
di Wilson così lui finalmente potrà
andare con la ragazza dei suoi sogni
Bravo cazzo il Joker
Prigionieri di un incantesimo due
fratelli vivono in campagna ma in questa
campagna ci vive anche una donna
misteriosa di cui loro hanno un pochino
paura un giorno durante un casino che
sta succedendo in un negozio cadono
addosso a questa donna e spaventati
scappano via poco prima che loro fuggano
la donna li indica e dice gallina
gallina e loro nei giorni successivi si
trasformano in galline iniziano a
beccare il mangime e iniziano a
starnazzare a destra a sinistra e
capisco che c'è qualcosa che non va
quindi vanno a casa della donna per
cercare di capire come tornare umani
fanno un casino Non ci riescono e la
donna li becca io non so se me la sento
di raccontarvi il twist di questa storia
non so se ho le forze Se non è giusto
secondo me nei vostri confronti
allora un po' come Drag Met Well di
sembraini la donna li ha trasformati in
galline Perché loro quando le sono
cadute addosso non hanno chiesto scusa
andando via e lei che studia il galateo
dicevo non mi avete chiesto scusa io vi
ho mandato una maledizione allora loro
ormai che si sono tipo trasformati in
pulcini saltano sulla macchina da
scrivere e chiedono Scusa scrivendo e
lei dal cuore d'oro dice ok accetto le
vostre scuse e li ritrasforma in umani
il twist è che lei dopo che si sono
trasformati in umani questa donna offre
una bibita al fratello il fratello la
beve e pianta un rutto fortissimo Non
sto scherzando tanto che la sorella
scoppia a ridere la donna li guarda e
dice maiale maiale
incuba al risveglio in un ragazzino di
12 anni con una vita de merda non riesce
a dormire sul letto di camera sua quindi
si intrufola nel letto della camera
degli ospiti e dorme lì solo che ogni
volta che si sveglia da questo letto ha
una vita diversa una volta otto anni poi
ne ha 16 poi ne ha quattro poi diventa
un vecchio Poi ne ha di nuovo 12 ma con
genitori completamente diversi e nel
frattempo viene anche inseguito da due
poliziotti della realtà perché sta
combinando un casino nello spazio tempo
capisce che magari andando a dormire
nella sua stanza normale non nella
stanza degli ospiti potrebbe tornare
alla realtà ed infatti così succede
torna alla realtà il twist è che la
madre che lo ha visto andare a dormire
nella stanza degli ospiti gli dice vabbè
allora A sto punto ti cambio stanza
dalla tua a quella degli ospiti e lui
urla il mio libro preferito Le avventure
del mostruoso blog Zac prima viene
colpito da un fulmine e poi trova una
macchina andare a vivere Siccome gli
piace scrivere storie dell'orrore inizia
a scrivere questa storia dove un blog
gigante assorbe le persone e le uccide
ma non si rende conto che tutto quello
che scrive diventa realtà perché il
fulmine glielo permette quindi c'è
questo blog gigante lui si implica e
tenta di cambiare la storia per
aggiustare la realtà il twist è così
twist che non ci arrivereste mai
tutto quello che noi abbiamo letto non è
la realtà è una storia che il blog sta
scrivendo e che sta facendo leggere a un
altro suo amico Blob Ma che cazzo dici
per questo è il mio libro preferito il
mistero del lago gelato una ragazzina
per fare pietà alle sue compagne di
campeggio decide di far finta di
affogare in un lago gelato quando torna
in superficie scopre che sono Tutti
spariti ed è rimasta soltanto una
ragazza fantasma questo fantasma vuole a
tutti i costi che la protagonista la
accompagni nell'aldilà quindi tenta di
ucciderla Ma grazie a Dio viene salvata
da una sua altra amica il twist è che
pure l'altra amica è un fantasma che la
vuole avere come compagna nell'aldilà un
amico invisibile al piccolo Sammy
succedono delle cose particolari durante
le giornate come se ci fosse un'entità a
seguirlo ed infatti un'entità c'è è un
ragazzino invisibile che vuole può
diventare suo amico se mi giustamente
Pensa che figata avere un amico
invisibile pensa quante cose potremmo
fare insieme ma purtroppo questo
ragazzino invisibile è un pezzo di merda
e gli combina le peggio cose e gli fa
fare delle figure di merda dando la
colpa a lui perché tanto lui è
invisibile grazie ad un attrezzo dei
genitori scienziati riesce a scoprire le
forme di questo ragazzino e scopre che è
umano e perché vi dico che scopre essere
un umano perché il twist finale è che
tutti quanti tranne il ragazzino
invisibile erano alieni
terrore dagli abissi 2 perché la storia
di merda non poteva non avere un seguito
i due fratelli sono tornati e a suo giro
Scoprono che c'è uno scienziato che sta
facendo degli esperimenti con il
Plankton e si scopre che chi mangia
questo Plankton diventa un pesce lo
scienziato tenta di far diventare tutti
i pesci con questo plancton ma per un
disguido non funziona quindi lo
scienziato pensa Porca miseria il
plancton non funziona Fammelo provare lo
beve e diventa un pesce il twist è che
alla fine del libro uno dei due fratelli
beve del tè che forse forse non si sa
potrebbe non essere del tema il plancton
è anche peggio del primo libro la scuola
maledetta due amici trasferiti in una
nuova scuola prendono per sbaglio un
ascensore e finiscono in una stanza
completamente in bianco e nero con degli
alunni in bianco e nero anche loro
bloccati lì dal 1947 a causa di un
fotografo che gli ha fotografati e
bloccati lì chiamato camaleonte grazie
ad un rossetto di una ragazza a scuola
che da colore a questo bianco e nero
loro riescono a fuggire a tornare nella
realtà il twist finale che tutti si
radunano per fare una foto di classe e
il fotografo che la fa si chiama
camaleonte La Casa dei lupi mannari Alex
viene mandato a casa degli zii in questo
quartiere lui conosce Anna una un'altra
ragazzina che abita lì con quei fa
amicizia perché sono entrambi
appassionati di licantropi quindi li
studiano e li cercano e Scoprono che in
una delle case del quartiere ce ne
potrebbero essere alcuni loro vanno alla
casa ma non solo non ci sono licantropi
ma la casa è abbandonata perché si
scopre che i licantropi sono gli zii del
protagonista loro due insieme riescono a
rompere la maledizione degli zii e a
farli tornare umani il twist del libro è
che in realtà anche Anna la sua amica è
un licantropo e tenta di azzannare il
protagonista molto banale C'è qualcuno
nel buio qui Seguitemi un attimo con la
trama che il twist ne vale la pena Marco
è un ragazzino a cui arriva una botta in
testa fortissima da una mazza da
baseball da dopo che ha preso la botte
in testa scopre che c'è nello scantinato
un altro ragazzino rinchiuso che però
non è un ragazzino è un mostro il povero
Marco è convinto che sia la botta in
testa a fargli allucinare questo mostro
quindi tenta in tutti i modi di capire
se sia vero o no ma il mostro a quanto
pare è vero il twist è che in realtà
tutta la storia era un sogno
ma non di Marco del mostro questo mostro
ha sognato un ragazzino di nome Marco
che prende una botta in testa e si
conoscono perché anche i mostri possono
sognare e siamo arrivati all'ultimo
libro che non poteva essere nient'altro
che il barattolo mostruoso numero 4 a
sto giro però non è un liquido che fa
diventare gigante le cose ma è un blob
blu che quando entra in contatto con
l'acqua esplode e si moltiplica i
protagonisti con un ragionamento molto
laterale pensano di ucciderlo questo
mostro dandogli da bere il sugo che ha
preparato la zia perché è piccantissimo
e quindi dicono magari questo non gli
piace il piccante e crepa invece il sugo
piccante lo rende ancora più aggressivo
Però così tanto aggressivo lo rende
questo sugo che iniziano ad azzannarsi
tra di loro e a uccidersi tra di che il
twist finale è che per sbaglio il vicino
di casa vede una bottiglia con questo
blog blu dentro e la beve e si
moltiplica
questo questo è l'ultimo libro della
prima serie dei Piccoli Brividi siete
stati anche troppo in nostra compagnia
Quindi andate pure rompete le righe Vi
ringrazio tantissimo per aver visto
questo video amo questa serie di libri I
twist sono incredibili del motivo per
cui amo I twist in qualsiasi storia un
saluto a shama Island e io vado a morire
perché sono distrutto
e stop Beh com'è andata
è venuto bene ma quand'è che me lo ridà
il canale
mai
C'è un motivo si va meglio da quando ci
sono io
[Musica]
Avete presente quando vi arrivano quelle
telefonate e dall'altra parte rispondo
una voce preregistrata e voi siete al
telefono e vi chiedete Ma come hanno
fatto ad avere il mio numero ecco
gliel'ha venduto un data Broker i data
Broker sono dei mostri di fango che
raccolgono i dati e numeri di telefono
delle persone per rivenderli alle
aziende quello che le persone non sanno
è che per legge tu puoi chiedere di
rimuovere i tuoi dati da queste liste ed
è qui che entra in gioco
incognitegni è un servizio che si occupa
di rimuovere i vostri dati da queste
liste perché se voleste farlo per conto
vostro ci mettereste anni e controllano
periodicamente che nessun data Broker
riutilizza i vostri dati con il link in
descrizione e usando il codice Yotobi
potete anche usufruire di uno sconto
cosa aspetti
[Musica]